okay for people joining the livestream
we are talking about design of some
machine learning capabilities full of
language and we're mostly talking about
a function called learn distribution and
maybe we can get a demo
Emira can you do a demo
you
yes just one second
so do we have a new guide page that has
information about the Sidhu we'd have
draft now is no we didn't do anything
documentation wise nothing a good time
to start right now is this in a build
that I can look at no it's in a branch
it's on a branch see you in a few and
[ __ ] don't look into oh yeah sorry he
didn't realize he was trying to okay
fine go ahead
[Music]
okay so let's take a look at the
distribution first and some derivative
functions like missing imputation
which based on learned distribution so
we have few methods at work we see the
methods here yes let's just say work on
amnesty for example wait wait show us
digit zero why is there an example okay
just charged digits not just digits
digit why did you use example data
rather than resource traitor there yes
why did you use example data rather than
resource data okay so now so then we can
just steal their learn distribution
the digit set of images and then we can
have different methods okay fine I don't
I don't care what's the default method
yeah so the default automation yes like
you can get a learning curve different
algorithms that it tries and it would
find the best one for example here's
okay alright so let's see that the
result of that let's to learn this trick
okay so LD random variate of LD yeah we
can do random variate given the learning
distribution and say like ten of them so
it's a little bit fuzzy but say there
are better like let's look at another
method say kernel density estimation
that needs autocomplete by the way yes
yes just I understand that learning
curve why they're these big are those
that look like it hadn't done very well
okay that's cool but that learn
distribution thing the the training
thing didn't look very promising there I
mean that is it seemed to be it seemed
to still have a very high error can we
see that again please
information okay
it has like 50,000 or something on the
verticals yeah it's true didn't show
well I think it's minus something some
big number normalization problem that
will fix it information
on that on LD on the yes unhealthy and
then you can you know at number of
examples so indeed the loss is like -
finds them - for but for some reason it
didn't show - I'm missing I mean I don't
what it means to have a negative loss
like that well it doesn't mean much when
you learn distribution I mean okay okay
what we have to document and what it
means that we take in the case of images
we are conforming them and then the PDF
reports it is in this multi-dimensional
space there is a space of all the pixels
each image is a ten so after
confirmation of the image that's at this
space in which we define distribution if
you put images there are different sizes
we won't try to capture the distribution
of sizes as well okay that's one thing
to normalize these things in the most
sensible way you're right actually
actually okay so the random variate is
magnificent now let's see some other
things like that see can we see the mean
of that distribution so it's numerical
distribution so there exist a mean but
in many cases the mean doesn't even
exist for example so that's why we
didn't implement me sorry we could have
mean for some specific in the case where
input is numeric something this is
because the pixel values I mean
fundamentally will be some gray blob or
sometimes yes yes actually you can do a
random variate just do mean on these
random variates and put 1,000 and
yes I mean of that God's I mean of the
random variables come this learnt
distribution what other things can I do
with the learned distribution for
example can I say X tilde tilde learn
distribution could I say expectation
value of something with X tilde you know
X distributed like the learned
distribution would that make any sense I
mean like for example if I said yeah I
mean as long as your function evaluate
to a numerical value which is also the
case in the current way well why would
it have to be the function I mean that
the trivial thing I try to say like show
me the you know show me the the I don't
know there's the edge detection of this
thing with X distributed I don't know
what that means anything you know edge
detection of a distribution with X edge
detection of an edge detect of X with X
distributed according to this learnt
distribution what that means something
or not distributions so it's missing
imputation I mean yes you have
distribution the only thing you can do
is random variates
or the PDF and sort of integrate that
level of integration with expectation
and probability and so on we're gonna
have to do separate work because that's
gonna be primarily simulation oriented
you know methods to compute those things
well but what makes sense I mean in
other words so let me give you an exotic
a let me see the two you can do that for
graphs for instance okay for graph
distributions you can compute you know
expected connectivity lengths and things
like that can I see that PDF please
could you evaluate it please okay
that is absolutely meaningless garbage
what the heck does it mean it's
meaningless call it just where but it's
a space in 728 dimensions so it's like
Delta is our Delta D Rock functions in
everything you need something this is
digits in the training data that's not
the thing to look at or to look at the
digits but we're not in the training set
yeah otherwise this is a kernel density
estimation so it's a bit of a nearest
neighbor so it might be a bit peaked
around the test data so there so theta
is much faster ah yeah no that's I
expect to see I expect to see something
I don't think it's meaningless I think
that these are you know we density
estimation these are almost like smooth
versions of the rocks shouldn't be
direct because they're not on you know
they're not on the point right these are
off the point of this and then - just to
see if we are in the - 50,000 as shown
by the learning curve and okay so they
are actually correct they are completely
correct if you put a random image you
need something much worse try try just
try just try random so it's true that
the space has seven only 20 dimensions
and so you have something I'm totally
confused I'm sorry but explain to me
what the heck's going on the integral
over all space for the probability is
the PDF is 1 right yes ok so how come
there are things that have you know
really big what's that
yes exactly the space is very
each dimension is a pixel value between
zero and one
so why is even the random image that big
I mean if you just have the random image
shouldn't be that big because look
there's going to be a lot of the space
that has nothing in it where it's
completely barren where there's no
possible values and I will thought that
prize let's see the random image could
you just show it random image please yes
yeah I don't - when you say close you
have to say I why is there a log I mean
the PDF better be equal to one which
means for most possible random images
the support there of the distribution of
the PDF should be zero for all practical
purposes that's true show me a place in
the PDF where we're getting 0 that's
automatic automation shows anything we
should let do what it does and it
actually picked Muccino more before then
because it didn't look nice ample I may
have put the kernel density no no no the
exact thing you've got here but but I
want to see whether this PDF I don't
believe this PDF right now let me give
you an application of the PDF okay which
is this originality measure thing that I
was looking at
in other words how unexpected is you
know you draw a digit how unexpected
original is that digit that's a bit what
I need fiction is yes yeah differently
like digit test for example then sorry I
should tell you that you should prepare
for presentation yeah okay all right
okay so let's this is a huge that's
documented one that's strange
okay okay so what we is respect let me
just understand a few things
so CDF makes absolutely no sense for
these multi dimensional distributions no
like statement yes
so Roger poke at some things here from
your statistics functionality and
probability distributions that you think
might be relevant
well Etienne and I have discussed some
so if you have ready to go at you why
don't you start yeah that also with
Stephen there's some nice things with
mutual information and we can an
extension of correlation that
correlation you can give to set of data
at the moment but they have to be
numerical so even if they have an
americorps it will give you know
something a bit better than just a
linear correlation and potentially we
can put any type more type of data
so what seem like a trapeze of
distributions does that make sense for
these yes yes yes we can go back to my
screen let me go back to my screen for a
second actually we entropy is not a
standard property that we support for
distribute
I mean but if this team adds these
extensions there's a lot of legacy stuff
to also support in that case or it's
something just for this yeah and this
time so what should we be looking at
here we should be looking at what I want
to see is okay so so estimated
distribution I'm trying to understand
the difference between estimated
distribution and learn distribution and
so on and that is fusion well yeah the
the nonparametric distributions have
built-in estimators when you give it
data and they just direct you know like
histogram distribution or smooth
histogram distribution they auto auto
estimate I understand so here you're
saying estimated distribution given some
parameters and the gamma distribution
you're saying what's the best gamma
distribution for this data that's right
okay
whereas for data distribution should go
to smooth histogram or you know yeah do
you see them a bunch of them there see
that this must take data in and what you
get back is two distributional
representation of that fine
that's basically what learn distribution
is doing right yes yes yes well this so
smooth kernel distribution so my next
question is if I give smooth kernel
distribution a bunch of pictures of cats
know is it going to no it's not going to
do anything
I I know it's not right now gonna do
anything but I'm asking should it in
fact call the learn distribution code
with method arrow smooth kernel as the
difference is that these guys do support
the full complement of properties for
distributions whereas learn distribution
does not at all I understand that I
understand that but so when you get a
smooth distribution out here yeah well
what's this gonna do Ida I guess like 35
of these properties now
I know okay
why did you hide the why did you hide
the output that seems like it's useful
to see what that is
anyway never mind okay so there's a
there's a okay so there's this thing
called data distribution I think that
the point of that example was not that
the point was to show that there is an
actual PDF and CDF yeah
I wish we didn't do this of combining
these things that they like no mind that
no I'm gonna see okay it takes smaller
XM you know her vertical height you know
I know okay
another case be that as it may the okay
so what I'm trying to understand the
comparison here between data
distribution and learn distribution okay
which I think has the wrong name okay I
think a huge thing is that there's a lot
of work there going on for to dealing
with extreme you know first of all the
all the encoding framework to map things
to quantitative things whether it's
categorical or I know if it's high
dimensional to reduce the dimension
there's a lot of work underway I realize
that but from the point of view of what
we're getting out I think what we're
getting out is a data distribution with
a type that says you know machine
learned whatever it is thing but
basically it's the data distribution
sorta but it comes with a bunch of other
things which are all these you know to
account for the time taken to train and
fit you know the animations of the
understand all of that
I understand but from the point of view
of functionality the thing we get at the
end is functionally equivalent to a data
distribution except that certain
properties like moments and things don't
exist for it we don't know how to
compute those right because why is that
well the reason for that is it's not a
one dimensional distribution it's a 715
dimensional distribution or something
and so the quantiles common sense
no no quanta doesn't but mean word if
it's numerical you know well if there's
a way to combine it which there is for
amateurs if it's a distribution over
words for example mean makes no sense
exactly which is fair to the Oracle
right
of a sort I think words are even
something yet different
I mean categorical as far as I'm
concerned is there are seven choices you
know here's what they are
that's the categorical distribution that
has that has a limited set of choices
and certain probabilities for those
choices right and you know that's what
we need to be able to support and that
sort of the minimal that's simpler than
almost everything we have here and we
should figure out how to support it but
that's a separate issue it is a separate
issue because there's a lot of things
they they will not support and there's
some other things that you want in
addition so it's a little bit of both
well okay fair enough but I mean things
like obviously mean doesn't make sense
for a categorical distribution but
neither does expectation for the same
reason right but okay so let's just take
a look for a second where do we have the
list of functions that are supported for
this all right I think I just finished
ood why the numbers were that crazy yes
and I read something we should probably
talk about so you should look at a
lanista there's some excel that are
basically always one value zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero so if you
actually want to compute the
distribution in the space of all pixels
it's actually infinity because you have
some basically Dirac so to speak for
some features but always the same would
you see what I mean and if the d-roc
with a width of zero because the
standard deviation is zero and I just
before when like the typical thing in
processing if it's worth saying
something there was only zero to just
assume there's a summation of one I just
changed that and and I realize that for
releases crazy problems let's say we had
a two dimensional distributing I think I
have an easy explanation Stephen yep so
if you can think of even a one
dimensional distribution you can have
what's called a mixed type of
distribution it's both discrete and
continuous
you want to think of it as a physicist
you might think of these Asturian the
PDF as Dirac spikes or if you look at
the CDF there there jump discontinuities
in the CDF fine it's like it's like
something with a perfect continuous part
to it spectrum and a discrete part
spectrum exactly
okay so and these are hard to end all
because you should query the PDF
normally it should actually be infinity
well mm well you know for the rock here
it's it's moving undefined value
effectively you know it's yes or if you
let's say you put one I mean you were
going to add to the example so if you
have a to distribution when everything
is exactly online then its PDF in the
two dimensional space will be undefined
in all the values on that line yeah on
that line and zero everywhere else and
that's that's a bit of a problem and so
okay there's one thing to realize that
the the PDF the actual value of the PDF
is not that meaningful in that setting
in for this function we do what we want
to know is is you know
variant of a PDF is lower for an example
to another example to know if it's
anomalous I want to climb PDF denoise or
to impute missing values to select the
region has a highest PDF so you say yes
yes yes and and so we taken some Liberty
to smooth the data so for example in
eminence you have this pixels are always
one always zero the automatic processing
will add a little bit of noise to smooth
these things and I realize in my last
commit I just completely removes noise
up too many min machine number or
something like this and that's what's
creating this craziness and that's
what's creating in multi normal this
because it's use arbitrary-precision but
even we arbiter position I think it's
out of out of range or something like
this that's what crazy is a precision
problem basically so I need to to
rethink that but also poses the question
about is it that meaningful to ask for
the PDF for this sort of stuff not
pointing low PDF instead what about a
likelihood I have to go okay I'm sorry
about that we may not be a
to continue meaningfully without Etienne
here and I think we shouldn't I think
it's it's a much more productive way
that in here it's just okay but but
let's just parameterize what it is we're
trying to understand I mean we're trying
to figure out and Roger let me just
address this with you for a second okay
so the fundamental point is we've got
this way of deriving a distribution that
seems to me very much like the data
distribution idea yeah it is okay so
with with with important additions you
know with all the encoders and dimension
reductions right well so there are many
processing processors that are involved
yeah I get it
I know it's much more complicated but
it's the same idea as you know estimated
distribution but with sort of a machine
learned it's something in between you
know the result is really a data
distribution except with more
complicated tentacles there right um so
in that sense yes it is the same idea
okay so to me the feeder should be some
function that is some kind of you know
we shouldn't have a separate thing
called learn distribution it should be
date
distribution is the Alpen and our data
distribution is just a container it's
there's no oh you mean the output should
be that yeah that's what I'm suggesting
how I see but then you know there's a
set of properties and other things you
know we're gonna have to conform those
that's I think some of them I mean look
it can say this is a data distribution
I'm sorry it's a it's a you know seven
thousand dimensional distribution over
things that don't make any sense to
compute quantiles for we should we
should have that discussion with Etienne
here because I don't know how easy
that's going to be because you know
think about it you know it's easy to
overload the documentation is hard to
overload because you're effectively
writing two sets of documentation there
now I understand rage I understand so so
let's take a look for example here at
data distribution
yeah I mean this says practically
nothing
right which is good for our purposes so
this is saying there are things that
that feed into this like empirical
distribution right and conceivably we
could have a thing called learned
distribution or something right that
could feed into data distribution so
instead of empirical distribution it's
called learned distribution and then its
output is a data distribution right it
could be with a fee yes okay but we need
to have that discussion in detail with
actually because they gone on to sort of
do their own thing looking at this but
we gotta sort of the Devils in the
details I think all right ok fine all
right well so much for that
all right let's sum we should wrap up
Roger
you and I have a meeting coming up for
soon which is also going to be live
stream so we could actually if we have a
chance maybe we can try and move that
meeting up by a few minutes actually you
know what no it's fine let's not do that
I've got something else I need to take
care of so I will see you at the top of
the next hour at the other meeting
sounds good and thanks all see you later